How would you define change?
Aristotle used to defend the existence of God by acknowledging the existence of change.
such as the mystery of the existence of consciousness.
Atheism cannot make Any moral claims because it has no moral framework.
I do believe humans have worth.
Number one there's an infinite cycle of change in the world.
without another frame of objective moral reference?
Who created the laws of the universe?
When you go down every change and fulfillment of change it leads to one unchanging force.
The struggle is better than pretending you have no meaning.
Not only do we have objective truths but what about objective morality.
Trash God all together and you can't explain why you believe in objective truth or morality.
Perfect. So if something is changing It is because there was potential for changing that thing.
If we understood God we would be like God,
Well who created the natural process?
We believe 2+2=4 because 2+2=4 always and everywhere. It's true.
Change is a fulfillment of the already existing potential for that thing to change.
For example, humans coming from the natural process which is the result of the laws of the universe
Let me ask you where do you think objective truth comes from?
Who gives us worth? Ourselves? The universe? Who gave the university authority to decide that?
2+2=4. You cannot possibly tell me that you believe that 2+2=4 because it's evolutionary beneficial.
Science kills God though.
But it's religion that often times causes people to do evil things.
Well evolutionary biologist would point to the idea
But individual constructed meaning carries no significance when it's not objective or shared.
Do you not see that's a circular argument though?
I would not want to live a life whose purpose is changing relative and dependent on myself.
but the belief in God inherently comes with the belief that you are not like God.
The natural process is a result of the laws of the universe.
Well the structure of the universe is a result of the natural process.
Science itself requires certain presuppositions outside of science
that our ability to comprehend a truth is no more than our ability to think
I believe God created the laws of science that tells us 2+2=4 just as He created objective morality.
Now no potential can be fulfilled unless an unchanging force changes it.
Okay so what's the other conclusion?
And I believe you believe that.
All change must be caused by something unchanging
I can live a life of meaning without believing in God.
Morality means nothing if humans have no inherent worth.
That I would say the contrary,
We make claims of truth beyond what is evolutionary beneficial all the time.
What do you believe in then?
I'm following you.
The belief in any moral ought requires us to believe in provable truths that must descend outside of ourselves.
whatever is most evolutionary beneficial for us in our genetic descendants.
That there's a purely unchanging force in the world.
This means there are 2 conclusions that we can come to.
Well I believe in the natural process.
which is the result of the structure of the universe and so on and so on.
Without a higher power we can’t objectively say what is good or bad.
Oh I don't.
I guess we will see who's right one day.
The struggle of the existence of God is part of religion.
Do you believe in God?
Well how can you judge whether the religion is promoting evil things
Or I would call God.
Yeah I believe God created me.